il y a quelques années
jallet de bon matin acheter mon pain est
là devant la boulangerie
j'ai assisté à une scène étonnante
déroutante même deux personnes se
disputaient si violemment que tout le
quartier
on a été à me tais un homme on dirait
aujourd'hui un sdf engueuler c'est le
mot anglais violemment pauvre dame d'un
certain âge très respectable ce qui lui
avait offert une pizza mais j'en ai rien
à faire de ta pizza vieille mégère
dégage la grande majorité des patients
dépassant les clients s'étaient
attroupés avait manifestement pris fait
et cause pour la vieille dame
et il commençait aussi à discuter avec
le sdf mais au foot et du monde
c'est même lamentable déjà vous traîner
dans les rues vous foutez rien cherchez
pas de job vous puis et puis là on vous
tend la main et à vous la mort d et en
plus on sait très bien si on vous donne
du fric vous allez tous qui collait le
soir même alors je n'ai pas pris parti
dans cette discussion ou pseudo aux
discussions mais je te dire que ça m'a
pas mal retourné ça m'a même inspiré
dans ma vie privée professionnelle plus
tard en france comme en afrique
ah oui parce que il faut que je vous le
dise je travaille dans la solidarité
internationale ah ouais je suis un type
bien
enfin je me soigne quand même hein alors
je vous rassure tout de suite je vais
pas vous raconter mes souvenirs des
missions façon indiana jones
quoique j'aimerais bien et puis je vais
surtout pas venir vous faire la manche à
la fin de mon intervention par vous avez
intérêt quand même à vous méfier quoi
j'ai commencé à sévir en guinée en 1996
en république
conakry pour la première fois j'étais
simple volontaire j'ai ensuite rejoint
pendant une bonne douzaine d'années un
bureau d'études spécialisé dans le monde
du développement comme anti puis entre
les deux j'ai fait une petite incartade
française quand même le temps de faire
des enfants ils me marier et j'ai
travaillé en banlieue parisienne pour un
plan local d'insertion par l'économie un
peu naïf certainement comme beaucoup
d'entre nous quand on part en mission
comme ça je pensais apporter des
compétences partager des savoir-faire en
fait très honnêtement avec le recul
aujourd'hui je dois dire que ce sont mes
collègues africains qui vont tout à prix
qui montent et niaiser comme on dit
alors bien sûr j'étais pas partie tout
nu quand même j'avais je crois sur les
bancs de l'école de l'université a pris
quelques méthodes notre fameuse méthode
cartésienne et je pensais que dans le
cadre des projets j'allais l'utiliser
j'allais me référer à des procédures
j'allais utiliser des outils pour
m'aider à programmer les activités
sa mère qu'est ce que j'étais naïf en
fait monsieur bien vite rendu compte que
c'était pas moi le patron je me faisais
mener par le bout du nez par l'outil
c'est l'outil qui décide et à ma place
ce que je veux devait faire alors bien
sûr vous me direz oui d'accord mais peut
pas à partir dans n'importe quelle
direction on peut pas faire n'importe
quoi il faut bien rationaliser
c'est clair que l'élément humain
pourrait compliquer quoi vous avez tous
fait cette expérience
quand vous demandez à quelqu'un vous lui
posez une question il vous répond oui
mais en réalité ils pensent non ça
marche pas mal comme ça avec les enfants
d'ailleurs tu aimes les légumes oui oui
papa
non en fait il les mange pas et je me
suis aperçu que ces outils non seulement
étaient devenus mes patrons mais ils
avaient tendance à formater l'autre à le
faire rentrer dans un moule qu'on avait
décidé pour lui pire que ça
ces outils on appelle ça d'ailleurs des
cadres logique ces outils étaient faits
de petites cases très petit tailleur
dans lesquels on pouvait difficilement
faire rentrer l'humain alors on y rentre
et des chiffres des numéros des
quantités derrière lesquels on oubliait
complètement qu'il y avait de l'humain
car c'est là un air de rien comme ça
mais l'histoire nous l'a appris ces
cases là
elles peuvent devenir des trains ils
peuvent devenir des trains vers le mort
alors j'ai vite compris que ces outils
c'était des monstres il était tellement
exigeant tellement complexe que on y
passait l'essentiel de notre temps pas
le temps d'aller sur le terrain pas le
temps d'aller discuter avec ces
populations qu'on était censé aider vite
vite vite rempli les remplissaient les
tableaux de bord parce que non contents
de programmer ses outils ils veulent
aussi contrôler j'ai même participé à
une mission de 3 4 4 rempli d'experts
partant sur le terrain pour voir si un
pauvre bénéficiaires rembourser bien son
crédit de 5 euros et si on n'y prend pas
garde on devient des technocrates de la
solidarité des technocrates du social on
devient finalement les adeptes de nu
nouvelle secte de l'efficacité et au nom
de la sacro sainte culture du résultat
il faut obtenir des objectifs de plus en
plus vite
je pense que certains d'entre vous devez
le vivre dans votre quotidien mais cette
culture du résultat c'est une culture de
machines
c'est une culture d'ordinateur ou un
plus un front toujours deux et ça
fonctionne pas comme ça avec l'être
humain c'est une culture d'experts
froide toujours plus avides de chiffres
de données quantifiables
c'est surtout une culture qui n'arrive
pas à intégrer dans ses paramètres qu'il
nous faut du temps pour apprendre pour
comprendre pour se tromper pour
trébucher recommencer et tout simplement
nous adapter à la réalité humaine
et puis franchement ça veut dire quoi un
résultat avec des hommes
estime-t-on que parce qu'on a réussi à
retrouver un job ou un logement pour une
personne au chômage ou sans domicile que
tout est terminé
cool les sorties de mon tableau de bord
estime-t-on que cette personne n'a
strictement rien à nous apporter que son
regard ne peut pas nous interpeller nos
sociétés alors depuis cinq ans j'ai
décidé de renaître de tenter autre chose
alors bien sûr il s'agit pas de jeter
les outils mais je les ai remis à leur
place sont des béquilles qui m'aide à
prendre des décisions pas plus si la
case n'est pas assez grande
c'est pas l'humain que j'aurais tracy
jeu l'augmentent j'expérimente une
nouvelle manière de faire elle est plus
incertaine
c'est clair mais elle est surtout
tellement plus humaine j'ai décidé de
remettre l'homme à sa place celle qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû quitter
au centre j'essaye de mettre en place un
dialogue bienveillant où chacun essayait
de comprendre l'autre de le respecter
sont essayé de s'imposer à l'autre dans
cette relation
il n'y a plus de donateurs de
bénéficiaires il ya simplement deux
personnes deux acteurs finalement deux
partenaires qui essaye de construire
ensemble de décider ensemble et de se
tromper ensemble aussi cette vision des
choses
pourriez me dire oui mais bon là tu vis
dans le monde des bisounours
oui c'est vrai d'une certaine façon
parce que elle impliquerait qu'on revoie
fondamentalement en profondeur notre
rapport aux autres d'ailleurs cela vaut
aussi bien pour les décideurs les chefs
d'entreprise les élus que pour les
citoyens et les salariés pourquoi vivre
dans la confrontation avec ses
catégories qu'on émet sur les autres
elle vaut aussi probablement pour les
travailleurs du social
par exemple repenser la relation entre
le médecin et son patient
en fait
allez soyons un petit peu fou tous
ensemble est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
expérimenter une autre famille manière
de vivre ensemble
alors depuis cinq ans j'ai accepté que
je ne pouvais pas tout anticiper et que
finalement le plus important c'était
d'abord d'accompagner l'autre de l'aider
à s'adapter pour qu'il construise lui
même sa propre vie
je l'essaie aujourd'hui avec des
services civiques sont jeunes
c'est cette génération y on dit
tellement compliqué
mais moi ils me font vivre il s'en fout
un peu comme moi ils sont un peu
déroutés par ma façon de faire aussi
dire joue pas toujours simple et on vit
une belle aventure
j'ai pris le risque donc de cette
aventure humaine
en acceptant de ne pas trop savoir où
elles me monneret
j'aime bien cette incertitude j'ai
surtout décidé de remettre en cause mes
certitudes et de m'enrichir en contact
de l'autre comme on dit en afrique je me
suis vacciné vaccinés contre la culture
de la prévision la culture de la
perfection sur tout et finalement si on
arrive à tous vivre ensemble c'est parce
qu'on aime bien nos petites
imperfections
j'ai décidé donc d'introduire dans ma
vie une bonne dose d'énergie et surtout
d'un argy créatrice j'ai choisi de plus
miser sur l'imagination que sur la
connaissance
je ne ferme aucune piste
figurez-vous va peut-être vous étonner
mais ça marche et ça marche même très
bien
et vous savez pourquoi
parce que les pauvres ils sont pas le
problème
ils sont la solution
et bon on a tellement cette tentation de
les regarder de façon si négative de les
ranger dans des cases
parfois même c'est terrible on leur ni
même ce qu'il reste leur dignité
moi c'est ce que j'ai entendu sur les
routes d'afrique talbani de france
laissez nous notre dignité
alors bien sûr on a tous un bon fond moi
le premier est évidemment moi quand même
envie d'aider quoi et puis la petite
voix qui se rappelle à nous la l'enfer
est pavé de bonnes intentions
mes amis africains qui se moquaient
souvent de moi me disait mais tu sais
jean christophe la vache ne rentre pas
dans l'enclos qu'elle n'a pas choisis
alors je vous propose de regarder ces
pauvres autrement comme des hommes et
des femmes part entière capable
d'innover et d'inventer de tenter des
choses pour vivre eux mêmes leur propre
destin pour le construire
et si vous avez le temps en sortant
regardez autour de vous connecter vous
internet ça marche dans le monde entier
c'est une énergie extraordinaire
peut-être devrons-nous re prendre du
recul par rapport à nos outils et nos
méthodes et puis
si je reviens en arrière que je me
remets dans la situation initiale là
devant la boulangerie alors je vais pas
vous dire que j'ai des réponses ça
serait faux mais peut-être que
finalement mon sdf là bas tout
simplement il aimait pas la pizza ou
sans joie
pour ça